来长度的话五十六来这款谁要谁来给我九块九块扣六
找得到你运气爆棚来九块九块啊
谁要谁来扣个六
找不到是正常的对啊
九块扣六那那边拥有的人多不
你不是说他是在一个在一个那个啥啥里面游的
来这款S码的这个是一个秋冬的一个裙子啊
水池来这一款帽子九十块
对我就说你不能给他买带贵的
两边有口袋腰后面带松紧腰
直筒裙格子的一个秋冬款秋冬款啊
来这款腰是松紧腰的
后面底边开叉
后面底边开叉的
来腰是半腰松紧
S码
S码来这款你家帽子说他说太厚
这是带了日啊
水库啊
腰围六十六十可以拉到六十八囤围
九十六可以拉到10296102来裙长裙长裙长是83阿优小姐姐好几天没来了
他是那个哪个叫啥来着
那个牛
叫什么那新西兰呢
他这个裙子买了应该收到了不那么多天了
来这个谁要二十九二十九扣个二小格子的一个直筒的面料嘎嘎好啊
两边有口袋
两边有口袋啊
来这一款原来是四十九的原来四十九的
现在二十九二十九谁要谁来扣个二
前前两天找墨镜
我感觉咋咋给我有点像呢
我也是东东东扔吧扔呢
就是出门找这个找那个来这一款我今天出门了
我我我本来是想的把那个钥匙拿出来
你知道吗
放桌子上
然后我走的时候男人就不要在包里找了
然后结果我出了门
我感觉又包里找了
没找到结果钥匙就让我扔家里了
又回去呢
左边有隐形脸
有风
空气库的这个A字群调门调门来这一款腰上面没有松紧腰的A字群哦
腰围六十二六十四天天晕晕呼呼的
横纹110120110120群长六十一群长六十一来这个裙子谁要九块九块扣一扣一
来喜欢的姐姐去扣九块扣一九块扣一九点九扣个一
小姐姐们
来这个这个其实好像是一个高货吧
这一个是一个毛毛的一个裙裤
没有牌没有标了
来这个毛毛的毛毛的这里有裤子
这里有裤子啊
这里是有裤子
哎
有风机裤的这里有风机裤
就容易糊涂
都是这样的
来这一款毛毛的裙子啊
毛毛毛毛毛的这个小短裙
这个这个天感觉好热
腰为六十二腿为九十九十四来群长四十三来这个裙子谁要谁来扣来来来二十九二十九扣三
喜欢的姐姐就扣二十九二十九
谁要谁来扣个三
来吧
má
t
我们一起出门的时候我只要拿好手机就行
其他的哈
都是他负责
来这一款
我们这出门基本上都是我拿着
我拿拿
个人拿好个人的
来就是车钥匙啥的
我拿着
来这一款来这个牌子的
少一个小裤子
少裤子少裤子
这个直筒裙
这个也不是说直筒裙
底下有点下摆的
底下有一点点这个下摆的
来这一款蓝色雾霾
这个是孔雀蓝
面料锯纸
来胸围胸围
90 94 90 94
来长度长度
91群长91
这个少一个扣
给你们配个扣
来这个19吧19扣2
19 19扣个2
来喜欢的姐姐就扣
19扣2 19扣2
来他每天都去游嘛
他自己还是给朋友一起
他真的意志力
那个你看游多少
多长时间了
来这个牌
这个牌
来给宝贝们看一下
标减了
标减了这个粉色的
这个是小码吧
这个感觉好小好小
没有写码
没有写尺寸
来这一款咱们来量一下
来来来粉色前面有口袋
前面有口袋面料锯纸帽子上有抽绳
每天有
对啊都女都几年了啊
来胸围胸围100 106
100 106
长度59
长度59他自己碰到就碰到
来这个谁要29 29扣8
29 29扣8
来你咋不给他一块去游了
29扣8
然后我老婆上每天都游的话
我都跟他一起去游了
来这个两面穿的
两面穿的这个手拉链
原来49的反正面都可以穿啊
反正面都可以穿来手拉链头
就少这个拉的直接到修拉链的地方
让他给你
装一个拉链就可以了
装一个拉链看手拉链头
来这一块咱们来量一下你们谁要
我来给你们秒杀给你们两边都有口袋啊
两面穿两面穿
对于脚不着地运动
我不行
来来来来胸围胸围126 130
126 130来长度的话
其实长度其实来这一款谁要谁来扣
谁要谁来扣
9块9块扣1扣1啊
来喜欢的姐姐就给我9块扣1啊
9块扣1 9块扣1啊
来喜欢的姐姐给我9块扣1 9块扣1啊
脚不着地的运动不行啊
烫腰腰脚不着地的运动就没有了
脚不着地的运动就没有了
好
有这个
不 shown
呆
坆
我们还是看呀
我这看呀
来这个小西装薄薄的
有扣有分 er
有扣有扣呀 单层单层很薄荡
他这个有领标
但是领标上啥也没写
啥也没写 水洗标是光的
来这款有一个裤子 单层单层的
看一下黑色的 看他的腰身
看他的腰身
前面有口袋
左边上面胸这个位置也有一个小口袋
这是男装吗
这就是男生穿的呀
这个外套
来来来 黑色黑色
我们来量一下
胸围 胸围 胸围
98 100 98 100
腰围86 88 86 88
长度72 长度72 长度72
来这款谁要29
29谁要谁来扣个2
29 29这个外套薄薄的啊
谁要谁来扣个2
单层单层溜薄溜薄的啊
来29谁要谁来扣个2
扣个2
来这个摆折裙
灰色的这个摆折裙两边有鞋扎口袋
两边有鞋扎口袋的来这个摆折裙灰色啊
像这种摆折裙有口袋的不多
来这个他好像也是一个高货
原来有五个色的啊
现在卖的就剩这个色了
来腰是松紧腰
两边有鞋扎口袋的来
腰围62可以拉到92
腿围的话腾围不限啊
来裙长的话是87
来
这一款谁要2929扣7
谁要谁来扣个7
谁要谁来扣个7呀
哇mg加的这个圈
这个a字群好看的
来来来两边有口袋两边有口袋
两边有声mg的啊姐妹们这个是mg加的
这个是m码
面料锯纸面料锯纸的
这个好久没看到了
这个好久没看到能穿的姐姐就哭啊
大家是
看他的腰腰围这个位置
在一个装饰扣两边有口袋啊
腰后面是松紧的啊
面料是锯纸的来这个裙子
腰围62可以拉到84
腿围138可以拉到140
裙长69
来这个裙子谁要9块9块
扣1
9块9块扣1
来这一款a字裙谁要谁来扣
9块9块扣1扣1
谁要谁来扣
那个不在吗
苹果气泡不在吗姐妹啊
这个裙子好看
哇
好看吗
姐妹们
这个紫色好看吗
标剪掉了没有标了
哇这个好好看
这个好好看圆领圆领的这个机啊
啊卫一
短的短的啊
底边是带抽绳的啊
下摆带抽绳下摆带抽绳后背光满
后背是一个光满光满的哇
这个这个好好看这个紫
这个紫好好看
这个我得留着等香娃吃完饭来
我帮我发一下图
胸围120122 120122
长度44
不不多见对哦你在呀
我说等等着你给我发图呢
等你吃完饭回来
来这个39啊39扣个3
39谁要谁来扣个3没有标了
应该是棉夹锯纸单层
棉夹锯纸单层
哇 这个紫的好好看哦
这个紫色好好看感觉我也喜欢
我现在就喜欢这种短的
你说你说这咋整
你说这咋整
就喜欢这种短短的现在
越老越喜欢短的了
来这一款
来西装面料的这个半身裙哇塞腰好瘦
还有点
哎人家起的早事情完成的早
来这一款后面有裤有裤牙
有拉链啊来
后面底边开个小叉
后面底边开个小叉西装面料啊
来所以空闲时间多我不行
来腰围64 66
你每天几点钟起床呀
哎
腿围腿围90 94
来裙长裙长57
来这个裙子谁要9块9块
扣7扣7
来喜欢的姐姐就给我9块扣个7
9元9元扣7扣7
这个收腰身的外搭
没有扣也没有扣牙
牌子这个牌
没有扣
也没有扣牙有腰伸啊
绣的上也少
绣的上也是没有扣没有扣牙
今天9点
但那他几点
来没有扣没有扣牙有腰伸有腰伸的啊
看看他的腰伸
来这个就是扣个外搭但是他没有扣
这个谁要我来量一下你们谁要9块
9块胸围胸围胸围
胸围86 96腰围74 82
长度长度86来这款谁要9块9块扣6
9块9块扣66点6点半哦那起的还
蛮早的我今天定的闹钟是5点半
我平时的话就是说最多也就6 6点就是
蹭死了也就六七点钟
就是哪怕我两点钟睡我也是这个点醒
你说这咋整
我每天都强制让我自己睡觉
睡觉不要再不要再看了
来这个卫衣来给把我们看一下没有标了
里边加薄绒的
卡其色卡其色
圆领圆领光满光满的啊里边加薄绒的
这个这个短款